there was such a stunning list of  impressive performances by actors and  supporting roles last year the AG news  branch was very hard-pressed to select  only 5 nominees the finalists include  one who already has an Oscar for a  leading role another whose whole  brilliant career has earned in  knighthood two honored veterans of stage  and screen and a young man whose first  film has exploded him into stardom  what all five share is a dogged desire  for perfection a riptide of integrity  and the uniquely individual insight that  elevates a craftsman to an artist the  nominees are James Coco for only when I  laugh  [Applause]  so John Gielgud for Arthur  [Applause]  Ian's home for chariot of fire  [Applause]  Jack Nicholson for rent  [Applause]  and Howard e Rollins jr. for ragtime  [Applause]  and the winner is Sir John Gielgud and  Arthur  John Gielgud and except in his behalf  thank you  [Applause]